courts almost never break the attorney
client privilege with the crime fraud
exception unless Donald Trump is
involved which has been happening a lot
lately the former president in 2024
Republican front-runner is the target of
at least five criminal investigations
stealing classified documents and lying
about it to the FBI and properly
interfering in the Georgia presidential
election tax fraud in New York and
plotting an Insurrection against the US
government and paying hush money to a
former porn star now a man involved in
that much drama needs an army of lawyers
but manga might as well stand for make
attorneys get attorneys
Paul closes in on Donald Trump his own
attorneys are being compelled to testify
against him which basically never
happens but isn't the attorney-client
privilege supposed to be absolute how
can the government Force Trump's
attorneys to turn on him well Trump is
learning what all Mafia bosses
eventually find out that you can't
enlist a lawyer to help you commit your
crimes and cover them up witness can't
remain nameless forever
I didn't hear that but before we get to
Trump's troubles or more specifically
his lawyers troubles we have to talk
about what is the attorney client
privilege the attorney client privilege
is a legal privilege that keeps
Communications between an attorney and
their client private the privilege
protects Communications made orally in
writing in person over the telephone and
in letters or emails the lawyer's
obligation to preserve the client's
confidence and secrets continues after
termination of the lawyer's employment
and that privilege can apply whether
you're subpoenaed for documents in a
lawsuit it can also apply if someone
tries to compel a lawyer to testify
under oath and the client is the person
who is said to hold the privilege that
means that the client can waive
attorney-client privilege freely but a
lawyer can't start running their mouth
without the client's consent but that
being said it only applies to
Communications containing legal counsel
for example if a business attorney is
providing business strategy rather than
legal advice that's not protected but
why does this privilege exist apart from
you know lawyers generally writing all
of these rules well the reason for the
privilege is to encourage clients to be
truthful with their lawyers
I'm gonna defend you either way it's
said that a client is thereby encouraged
to communicate fully and frankly with
the lawyer even as to embarrassing or
legally damaging subject matter and the
idea is that when a lawyer knows the
client's version of the story the lawyer
can test that against the evidence
produced by the other side of the
government and in this sense the
privilege doesn't subvert a Court's
ability to find the truth it facilitates
it and because the privilege applies to
both criminal and civil matters it's an
essential part of the Fifth Amendment
privilege and self-incrimination a
person cannot be compelled to offer
testimony that might hurt his or her
case under the advice of my counsel and
for all of the above reasons I
respectfully declined to answer the
questions under the rights and
privileges afforded to every citizen
under the United States Constitution if
the person's lawyer could teleport
everything that the client said then
there'd be no meaningful fifth amendment
protection but there are some
limitations to the scope of the attorney
client privilege for it to apply there
has to be an interim client relationship
for a specific matter courts have
rejected the contention the person can
have a lawyer for every issue that might
arise in their life in other words your
conciliary can't remain quiet about
everything that they know about you this
principle was Illustrated in the 1990s
when mob boss John Gotti was indicted
for the murder of Paul Castellano the
presiding judge a disqualified Gotti's
lawyer Bruce Cutler and his two
Associates George chargell and John
Pollock from representing Gotti the
government had wire tapes from one of
Gotti's clubs where Gotti was caught
chatting about his lawyer's
participation in criminal activity and
during a hearing on the matter the
prosecutor played a tape from Gotti
whining about how much money he was
paying the three lawyers Gotti says
where does it end Gambino crime family
this is the chargell Cutler and who do
you call it crime family a pro tip if
organized crime doesn't pay enough
become a lawyer it'll scratch the same
itch
but Gotti argued that since Cutler
represented him in everything he could
never be a witness against him a Court
ruled against the Teflon Don concluding
that the lawyers represent not merely an
individual client but the Enterprise
with which that individual is associated
and receive instructions calculated to
further the interest of that Enterprise
the three lawyers were disqualified
because quote their participation in the
events underlying the obstruction of
justice count and this issue even came
up when the Stormy Daniels payments
first came to light before Michael Cohen
turned on Trump
simultaneously claimed that he relied on
Cohen's advice and that he had no idea
what Cohen was doing with the Daniel's
payments leading some observers to
question whether attorney-client
privilege even applied in that case
Cohen was a fixer and lawyer but if he
wasn't acting as a lawyer with the
purpose of the Daniel's payments then
the privilege wouldn't necessarily apply
and that of course brings us to the big
limitation on attorney-client privilege
the crime fraud exception which states
that legal advice that is used in
furtherance of illegal or fraudulent
activity is not privileged in 1989 the
Supreme Court explained that the purpose
of the crime fraud exception to the
Eastern decline privilege is to assure
that the Seal of secrecy between lawyer
and client does not extend to
Communications made for the purpose of
getting advice for the commission of a
fraud or crime for the crime fraud
exception to apply the client must have
been in the process of committing a
crime or planning to commit a crime if
the exception applies a court or grand
jury can subpoena the lawyer and the
lawyer must disclose the information and
sometimes the attorney is affirmatively
obligated to report that information
like when a witness is in danger or
missing or when there are serious or
immediate threats of harm now in the
criminal context the government must
generally establish by clear and
convincing evidence two things one that
the client Target was committing or
intended to commit a crime and two that
the client Target's attorney was used to
further that crime or conceal the
criminal activity if the government can
prove those two elements then both the
attorney client and work product
privileges are pierced the exception
applies only to the documents and
Communications themselves that were in
furtherance of illegal or fraudulent
conduct the tldr of the crime fraud
exception is that it if the client uses
Attorney Services to commit a crime
Communications made in furtherance of
that crime aren't protected and The
Government Can compel the lawyer to
produce records and testify against his
or her client now while the invocation
of the crime fraud exception is
extraordinarily rare in practice this
seems to keep happening with Donald
Trump's lawyers you might recall the
first recent example was that John
Eastman tried to help Trump remain in
office even after he lost the election
and when the January 6 committee asked
for communications with Trump Eastman
raised the attorney client privilege
because he was his lawyer but using a
preponderance of the evidence standard a
California District Court ruled that it
was more likely than not that Eastman
and Trump had quote attempted to
obstruct an official proceeding by
launching a pressure campaign to
convince vice president Pence to disrupt
The Joint session on January 6. now in a
civil case the burden of proof for the
party seeking disclosure under the crime
fraud exception is a preponderance of
the evidence meaning more likely than
not or you know just more than 50
percent likely now that exception does
not require a completed crime or fraud
but quote only that the client has
consulted attorney in an effort to
complete one the exception applies even
if the attorney does not participate in
the criminal activity and even if the
communication turns out not to help and
perhaps even hinder the client's
completion of a crime and an attorney's
wrongdoing alone may pierce the
privilege regardless of the client's
awareness or innocence Now using the
standard the court concluded that the
crime fraud exception applied to at
least some of the emails sought by the
January 6 committee the court
characterized the Eastman plan as a coup
Dr Eastman and president Trump launched
a campaign to overturn a democratic
election an action unprecedented in
American history their campaign was not
confined to the Ivory Tower it was a
coup in search of illegal Theory however
once that theory turned into action the
Eastman Communications became part of a
crime the action started when Eastman
sent Rudy Giuliani a memorandum that
included a plan of action for handling
the electors on January 6 2021. The
District Court concluded the quote this
may have been the first time members of
President Trump's team transformed a
legal interpretation of the Electoral
account act into a day-by-day plan of
action the draft memo pushed a strategy
that knowingly violated the elect
account act and Dr Eastman's later memos
closely track its analysis and proposal
the memo is both intimately related to
and clearly Advanced the plan to
obstruct The Joint session of Congress
on January 6 2021 because the memo
likely furthered the crimes of
obstruction of an official proceeding
and conspiracy to defraud the United
States and is subject to the crime fraud
exception and the court orders it be
disclosed now Eastman argued that there
was nothing wrong with writing a memo
that described a way for Pence to
discard electoral votes as long as his
legal analysis was made in good faith I
mean it's amazing well did I read your
memo and I thought it was solid in all
of its legal arguments yeah I just I was
floored that than Mike Pence didn't do
anything I mean why didn't he act on it
because you gave him the legal reasoning
to do that I know I know the judge
concluded that Eastman's actions could
have been against the law quote Dr
Eastman argues that the plan was legally
Justified as it was grounded on a good
faith interpretation of the Constitution
but ignorance of the law is no excuse
and believing that the Electoral account
Act was unconstitutional did not give
president Trump license to violate it
disagreeing with the law entitled
president Trump to seek a remedy in
court not to disrupt a constitutionally
mandated process the illegality of the
plan was obvious our nation was founded
on the peaceful transition of power
epitomized by George Washington laying
down his sword to make way for
Democratic elections ignoring this
history president Trump vigorously
campaigned for the vice president to
single-handedly determine the results of
the 2020 election now that brings us to
the recent bombshell allegations
involving Trump's new lawyer Evan
Corcoran and the Mar-A-Lago documents
case special counsel Jack Smith is
currently presenting evidence about the
classified documents case to a grand
jury in Washington DC Smith asked the
district court to allow him to question
Corcoran about a phone call he had with
Trump on June 24 2022. prosecutors
believe that the phone call discussions
were in furtherance of illegal activity
and they asked the presiding judge Beryl
Howell to pierce the attorney-client
privilege prosecutors wanted to know
what Trump said and whether he gave
Corcoran any orders about how to handle
the government subpoenas so how did
Corcoran find himself in this
predicament well you might remember
Trump's quest to stop the government's
investigation by appointing a special
master who would in theory slow or shut
it down when the parties were battling
it out in court the doj filed a response
explaining that Trump's lawyers
certified in early June that a quote
diligent search of Mar-A-Lago had only
turned up 38 classified documents all of
which were supposedly kept in a secure
storage room Christina Bob signed a
document asserting that the search was
complete or probably attesting that she
was informed that a diligent search had
been completed but when the FBI did the
first search of Trump's club with his
consent Corcoran was at Mar-A-Lago he
quote explicitly prohibited governed
Personnel from opening or looking inside
any of the boxes that remained in the
storage room given no opportunity for
the government to confirm that no
documents with classification markings
were made Corcoran told investigators
that he had been advised that all of
Trump's remaining records from the White
House remained in that storage room
presumably Christina Bob was the person
who advised him that all the remaining
records were in that storage room but
Trump might have told them that as well
but then in August of 2022 when FBI
agents served a warrant on Mar-A-Lago
they found more than 100 additional
classified documents the doj said that
some of these documents were located
outside of the storage unit now there
are basically two ways that this could
have played out either Corcoran knew
that there were other classified
documents inside Mar-A-Lago and he
deliberately misled the investigators or
Trump and his minions misled his legal
team and the lawyers unwittingly
repeated the lie to the investigators
and based on Judge Howell's order it
looks like Trump purposefully misled
Corcoran and the other lawyers and in a
sealed filing judge Hal concluded that
the prosecutors in Smith's office had
made a prima fascia showing that the
foreign president had committed criminal
violations and that attorney-client
privileges invoked by Corcoran and
Jennifer little could therefore be
pierced such findings are
extraordinarily rare but judge Howell
made a similar finding in Robert
Mueller's cases against Rick Gates and
Paul manafort I judge Howell ruled that
Gates and manafort hired a lawyer and
fed her deliberately misleading
information to conceal that they were
working for a putin-backed Ukrainian
political party the lawyer then
submitted a letter that was full of that
misleading information judge Hal ruled
that the crime fraud exception applied
in that case as well and here judge
Howell made a similar ruling for similar
reasons sources added that Hal had also
ordered Corcoran to hand over a number
of Records tied to what Hal described as
Trump's alleged criminal scheme those
records included handwritten notes
invoices and apparently transcriptions
of personal audio recordings yes it
appears that Corcoran has recordings now
we don't know if Corcoran recorded his
conversations with trump it wouldn't be
the first time that one of Trump's
lawyers recorded a conversation with him
which is not normal by the way or if
these are just conversations with other
lawyers or with Trump's employees but
judge Hal probably didn't make that
ruling based on a guess about what
Corcoran might have it's very likely
that Smith actually asked Corcoran what
records he had and Corcoran cooperated
by answering truthfully that doesn't
mean the Corcoran disclose privilege
information contrary to Trump's rights
in that case there's no legal reason why
a lawyer has to withhold the fact that
certain categories of documents and
things like documents and recordings
actually exist
but at that point Corcoran probably then
properly invoked the attorney-client
privilege about the contents of what was
in those categories of things however
here it's likely that the judge ruled
that Trump was lying to his lawyers
about a criminal scheme and therefore
Corcoran had to cooperate and you can
see the buying the Corcoran is in here
he might have unwittingly participated
uh in his own client's criminal
Enterprise and maybe that's why there
are recordings he certainly knew what
had happened with his predecessor Alex
Cannon and Michael Cohen now Trump
briefly and I do mean briefly got a
temporary stay of Judge Howell's order
the DC circuit uh the court of appeals
ordered Trump's lawyers to file a
memorandum of law that day on Wednesday
March 22nd at midnight and the doj's
response was due six hours later at six
o'clock in the morning the following
morning that's a briefing schedule I've
literally never seen in my entire life
and by Wednesday afternoon the DC
circuit had ruled against Trump and his
lawyers but since grand jury proceedings
are secret we can't show you that order
because it's not public so now
prosecutors will get to ask Corcoran if
he reviewed Christina Bob's affidavit if
he made any attempt to edit it and
whether he knew that there were other
documents in an unsecured location Now
sources say that lawyer Jennifer little
will also have to testify before the
grand jury because she was covered by
Howell's sealed order uh Jack Smith
probably wants testimony from Little
even though she never entered an
appearance as Trump's lawyer with the
documents case so we can only speculate
as to her involvement on May 3rd and 4th
2022 little uh posted photographs of
herself at Mar-A-Lago we don't know if
these photos were actually taken on the
dates that they were posted however
those days are particularly significant
on May 1st 2022 Corcoran asked Nara for
more time to gather documents and on May
3rd and 4th little was apparently at the
scene then on May 5th Elena Haba another
one of Trump's lawyers searched
Mar-A-Lago for documents responsive to a
subpoena from the New York attorney
general now perhaps little was on hand
to search the private club for
responsive materials she might have been
there to assist Corcoran Haba or both we
simply don't know this time but as you
can see Smith is seeking testimony money
from everyone who was involved in or
aware of the movement of boxes around
Mar-A-Lago and the location of the
documents Now ABC News reported that
Fannie Willis the D.A in Fulton County
Georgia wants to hear from Christina Bob
even though she doesn't represent Trump
in the Georgia case Bob's criminal
lawyer said she will refuse to testify
in that particular case and then there's
Lena Haba she's already testified to the
grand jury in February she represents
Trump in the New York attorney general's
case and when she searched Trump's
residence in private office uh honor
about May 5th she said that she found no
responsive documents and one of the
thorny issues is that if she did see
classified documents she didn't have the
clearance to actually examine them and
when she did her search it looks like
most of the classified documents were
still in the storage closet where they
were moved before Corcoran did his
search and the story closet isn't in the
residence or Trump's office and the
emerging theme Here is that these
lawyers might be witnesses to potential
crimes and their testimony would be
useful in proving that Trump may be
purposefully instructed lawyers to
search areas where no classified
documents would be found or instructed
them to tell investigators not look in
certain places or told other people to
remove boxes to hide them from
investigators or lawyers it's a mess now
losing an attorney client privilege for
Crime fraud is just the latest legally
unprecedented move involving Trump
there's so much stuff that I can't
release everything on YouTube but thanks
to the power of today's sponsor nebula
you can watch all my videos ad free and
early because my videos always go up on
nebula first plus there's tons of
exclusive content for example when you
sign up for nebula directly you can get
access to nebula classes which includes
my entire course how to sue like a
lawyer that used to be hundreds of
dollars a year now it's free and
included with your direct nebula
subscription you also get access to
nebula only videos like the Deep dive
that we took on Trump's criminal mental
state for the various crimes that he's
accused of and the crimes that Steve
Bannon was pardoned for and that's just
a few of the tons of exclusive videos
that are only available on nebula and I
make exclusive content on nebula all the
time because what's truly special about
nebula is that is a Creator owned
platform built by me and other YouTubers
and podcasters and because it's a
subscription service we get to work on
larger higher budget Productions than we
ever could on YouTube so if you sign up
using my link that's on screen right now
you get an annual subscription for just
thirty dollars which is 40 off the
regular price you'll get all my videos
early and get access to exclusives and
support the ambitious projects that my
friends and I are working on on our own
streaming site so sign up now and get 40
off I click on the link below and get
nebula for only thirty dollars a year
and then after that click on this box
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court